(birds chirping)
("Consistency" by Mr Truth City)
- So while you're getting your
degree or aspiring or sitting on
your couch and dreaming, it
just comes down to doing and for
sports personalities there's
no greater place than Twitter
because there's so much
conversation and if you're a
well-rounded sports person and
have thoughts on everything from
the NHL to MMA you can actually
have unlimited opportunities to
produce two
minute videos all day,
every day, forever on subject
matters that are trending and
being talked about all of
which are giving you greater
opportunity to be discovered
because people are hitting those
hashtags, watching
those conversations.
You can reply to people
that are more famous than you.
You can reply and make content
in response to another famous
writer or athlete
talking about it.
It's just gaming the system.
You can go and walk into any
conversation in any park in the
world right now, if there's 20
people talking about something
and none of them know
what you, sports is amazing.
20 guys standing around in a
park debating LeBron versus
Jordan and you could literally
walk up to that park and you
just start talking and
you're part of the mix.
And you may make the point that
won or changed the conversation.
Or you said the ridiculous thing
that got everybody to kick you
out but that's what Twitter is.
Twitter is incredible for
that especially for sports
commentators and I'm just so sad
because I get an email every day
from a kid in
Michigan and Syracuse like,
"Gary, I want to be
in the sports business.
"Can you help me get an
internship at the Daily News?"
I'm like, are you stupid?
That's a needle in a haystack.
And that's still how people
are thinking about it even
22-year-olds that
are natively being,
living in this environment.
There's such an opportunity
on Twitter for sports.
It's so crazy.
- [Stephanie] Daily News
is on Twitter.
- Yeah, and not only
that, their writers are,
the athletes are,
the coaches are,
the news editors and everybody,
is there anything trending on
Twitter right now about sports?
- [DRock] As of
right now, (inaudible).
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Michael Phelps, great.
Michael Phelps is
trending right now,
let's see why.
Michael Phelps
racing a shark reminds me...
Michael Phelps is apparently
tired of racing humans,
he's decided to take on a shark.
This is real.
- [Stephanie] Yeah.
- My replying right now to
the USA Today and being like
Michael Phelps is a genius.
What people
don't understand is...
Fuck it, I'm gonna do
it anyway my damn self.
I'm just gonna do it.
Something I don't normally do.
Hey guys, just
testing something.
I'm writing my
new book Crushing It
and I'm giving an example of
something I think is smart to do
on Twitter so
I'm jumping into this
Michael Phelps is
racing a shark article.
First, I'd normally probably
triple check and make sure it's
real news, it's true
but USA Today
I respect and trust you.
So, here's where I'm going.
I think
Michael Phelps is a genius.
I think he's hacking culture.
I think that there's a white
space for somebody to play the
Evel Knievel of 2020, 2018.
I think Michael is clearly still
passionate about swimming and
things of that nature so that's
an interesting insight that he's
going down this path if he is
'cause again I didn't triple
check but I'm just doing this
on a whim testing something.
But my punchline in
this is this is brilliant.
This will capture
some attention.
I have no idea how fast sharks
are or if he can beat 'em but if
he beats a shark,
I think that leads to
the next race
which is interesting.
And so, I would pay $20
for a pay-per-view of watching
Michael Phelps swim
against a something.
Which you pay $20 to watch
Michael Phelps
race against a shark?
- [Tyler] Yeah, if I could
one click through Apple Pay.
(group laughter)
- I hope you guys heard that.
- [Tyler] No, but like for real.
- That's it.
And basically what
I just did right now--
- [Stephanie] Uh-huh.
- So here's where it
gets interesting, right?
So I replied in
video form to this, right?
Right?
And so everybody replied.
Let's wait and
see if it shows up.
It's not uploaded yet but
I'll show you in a minute.
So, that's it.
That's what I think Dunk should
do if Dunk decided to take his
huge Instagram basketball page
if he wanted to
start branding himself.
- Mhmmm.
- He obviously can start
making content on Instagram
and putting on that account.
He's a huge account,
2 million plus.
What do you got, Dunk?
- [Dunk] 2.2.
- Right, he's got 2.2 million
followers on that account.
Like huge audience but I
still think what's amazing about
Twitter is back to when
Paul George broke his leg during
something and if he's opinion
is these players should not be
playing in the
Olympics or whatever it is,
it's that one piece of content
in a Twitter environment that
disproportionately
can be impactful.
("Consistency" by Mr Truth City)
Crushed It is dead,
we're back to Crushing It.
Tyler, what's the subtitle?
Crushing It, can't remember
what's the exact subtitle is?
How these, what?
- [Tyler] How great
entrepreneurs build their
businesses and influence
and how you can too.
- How great entrepreneurs build
their businesses and influence
and how you can too.
Crushing It. 2018.
Pre-order 50 copies now.
It's not up yet.
("Consistency" by Mr Truth City)